Land und Brecht
[Musik]
guten Morgen Markus guten Morgen Richard
heute mal umgedreht sehr gut ja wo
erwische ich die
an einem
strahlend schönen Sommer sagen
Spätsommer früh Herbsttag in einem sehr
schönen Podcast Studio in Hamburg und
ich stelle immer wieder fest da gab mit
dem Fahrrad durch die Stadt geeiert
Hamburg bei schönem Wetter also ich sag
mal so da musst du schon auffahren um
was Besseres zu erwischen
wirklich Hamburg im frühen Herbst
großartig wenn es ausnahmsweise nicht
regnet und du so ein jahreszeitenlosen
Frühlingstag im Herbst erwischt
unvorstellbar und dann du durch planten
und Blumen laufen ja oder oder an der
Außenalster links früh morgens
so atemberaubend schön so gegen sieben
so ganz ganz tief stehende Sonne und
dann unter irgendwie verändert sich die
Farbtemperatur somit mit beginnendem
Herbst und dann irgendwann rein im
Winter ich mag so gerne es ist so schön
und wenn du da so entlang juckst ja was
geht hier durch den Kopf
idealerweise nichts das ist ja der Sinn
von Joggen für mich immer das hat sowas
kontemplatives sowas meditatives ja du
läufst und du denkst und alles Rast
unter dem Kopf und so weiter und du
bereitest dich irgendwie gedanklich auf
Gespräch auch auf das jetzt hier vor wie
gesagt okay wo kann ich den Richard
heute packen und du kommst in einen
Zustand wo wo du jetzt nicht wo es nicht
das Gefühl hast du bist schwindelig von
den Nachrichten und es ploppt und es
piept und es twittert und es fordert
dich zum Widerspruch auf nee irgendwann
einfach nur noch sein nur noch atmen nur
noch ein aus du bist eigentlich nur noch
mit Überleben beschäftigt und das ist
gut hast du Sympathien dafür wenn Rolf
du belli der hat gesagt man sollte sich
quasi aus den sozialen Netzwerken
Zurückziehen der hat sogar gesagt man
sollte eigentlich Tageszeitung das macht
ja auch der seit zehn Jahren glaube ich
keine Zeitungen kann Fernsehen kein
nichts wenn du das nicht beruflich ja
würdest du dann auch dahinter tendieren
pass auf
da triffst du jetzt gerade einen total
guten Punkt Rolf du belli schätze ich
sehr ich bin ab und zu mal auch im
Kontakt mit ihm und ich ich ich erzähle
immer meine kleine Geschichte mit Rolf
Dobelli die geht so
du triffst diesen Mann du liest seine
Bücher und du denkst irgendwann okay der
ist vollkommen verrückt und dann kommt
dieses Buch über über diese
medienabstinenz ja wie so ein eremiti
also ein geistiger Eremit der in einer
intellektuellen Wüste irgendwo in der
Schweiz vor sich hinlebt und
wieder almöhe eigentlich umgestellt eben
gar nicht vor genau
und vielleicht ist er halt und das ist
der Punkt irgendwann kippt er das bei
mir und ich fing an wieder und wieder
darüber nachzudenken und ich frage mich
seitdem immer öfter was wäre das für
eine Welt wenn wir einfach alle keine
Tagesschau keine Nachrichten keine
Medien mehr konsumierten wäre die Welt
möglicherweise ein besserer Ort oder wer
sie ein schlechterer Ort wenn wir uns
nicht sozusagen die ganze Zeit
informieren
und Rolf stobelli vertritt ja die
wirklich harte these du verpasst nichts
wenn du weder Fernsehen noch Zeitungen
noch irgendetwas anderes liest und schon
gar keine sozialen Netzwerke was soziale
Netzwerke angeht kann ich ein bisschen
mitreden
ich bin da nicht auch wenn es
gelegentlich Leute gibt die sich als
meine Person ausgeben aber ich bin es
nicht ich lese das auch nicht und ich
tue das auch absichtlich nämlich um mich
zu schützen und ich ertappe mich immer
wieder dabei wie ich dann auch Foren
lese zum Beispiel unter unter Artikeln
die ich gut finde und immer wieder
feststelle da gibt es sehr viele schlaue
Leute die sehr schlaue Dinge
kommentieren ich erhole mir daraus oft
Anregungen und bin immer voller
Bewunderung was für für kluge Menschen
eigentlich in diesem Land zu unterwegs
sind
aber ich halte mich daran um wie gesagt
um mich zu schützen und a weil es
teilweise sehr schmerzhaft ist jeder der
dir erzählt ist macht ihm nichts aus
wenn er wenn er richtig in die Pfanne
gehauen wird der lügt ist nicht wahr ich
weiß ich habe mit Ursula von der Leyen
mal vor vielen Jahren darüber gesprochen
und die sagte auf die Frage ob sie denn
irgendwann so eine Dickfelligkeit sich
zugelegt hätte in Sachen Kritik und sie
meinte glauben Sie es mir oder glauben
Sie es nicht aber mit den Jahren wird
man Fell immer dünner und ich werde
immer empfindlicher und ich verstehe das
ich kann das gut nachvollziehen
irgendwie ich glaube es gibt so ein
Reservoir ja bei dem man einstecken kann
und einstecken kann und irgendwann ist
einfach mal gut und irgendwann erträgst
du es nicht mehr und das ist also der
eine Grund und der andere Grund ist ich
möchte
sozusagen nicht ideologisch in die ein
oder andere Richtung getrieben werden
ist für mich eigentlich noch der
wichtigere Grund ich möchte ganz
unabhängig und frei im Kopf bleiben und
das sagen und denken was ich wirklich
meine und wenn es dann auf die Mütze
gibt gibt es auf die Mütze und wenn
jemand sagt das ist gut dann freue ich
mich auch darüber ich kriege das dann
schon mit ja so indirekt aber ich will
diese Unabhängigkeit haben das ist mir
extrem wichtig und deswegen frage ich
mich ehrlich gesagt Richard jetzt mal
zurück gefragt an so einem Tag wie heute
ja du gerade mit Harald Welzer auch in
aller Munde große sterngeschichte große
Zeitgeschichte wie geht's dir denn wenn
sich dann plötzlich so dieses grelle
Licht der Öffentlichkeit so auf dich
richtet ich ich habe mich heute morgens
oder bei ertappt und dachte boah ich
möchte das nicht ich möchte das jetzt
nicht ich das ist anstrengend das ist
anstrengend sehr anstrengend es ist auch
überhaupt gar nicht so ein
beneidenswerter Zustand
sondern man beschäftigt sich ja mit
diesen Dingen wie zu Frage nach den
Medien nicht um anschließend 400
Interviews dazu zu geben sondern man
beschäftigt sich damit weil man denkt
das ist eine wichtige Frage wo Du gerade
gesagt hast weiß ich möchte sagen können
was ich denke
möchte das ausdrücken können natürlich
ist das schön wenn viele Menschen das
Aufgreifen aber dieses so völlig im
Blitzlichtgewitter stehen
behagt mir gar nicht abgesehen davon es
fängt schon damit an dass ich enorm
ungern fotografiert werde ja und das
sind auch so Dinge die sich nicht
vermeiden lassen
also es ist es ist nicht der
beneidenswerteste Zustand der Welt
irgendwo im Blitzlicht Gewitter zu
stehen und das ist auch nicht der das
Motiv warum ich mich mit bestimmten
Fragen wie zum Beispiel jetzt die Frage
nach unseren Leitmedien warum ich mich
damit beschäftige
ich meine das Thema
Journalismus die Frage nach den Medien
das ist ein ein Thema das auch mich soll
ich dir ganz offen jeden Tag in der
Arbeit beschäftigt und auch wenn ich
irgendwo einfach mal ein bisschen
Freizeit habe und und unterwegs bin
nämlich oft Frage welche Rolle spielen
wir da eigentlich
wie wichtig oder unwichtig ist das was
wir da tun welche Verantwortung haben
wir da eigentlich
und es gibt es gibt so ein paar zum zum
Thema Ideologie es gibt es gibt heute
kam raus oder dieser Tage kam raus eine
Studie
von der TU Dortmund
Michael Steinbrecher der die dem wir
beide kennen mittlerweile Professor für
Fernseher und Videojournalismus an der
TU Dortmund ist der früher viele
bemerkenswerte Interviews geführt hat im
ZDF vor allen Dingen
und diese Studie hat
zum Ergebnis gehabt das 41 Prozent der
Bevölkerung der Meinung sind dass die
Glaubwürdigkeit des Journalismus durch
die corona-berichterstattung abgenommen
hat
das ist ein alarmierender Wert es gibt
eine aktuelle Studie und die besagt dass
nur etwas mehr als 30% der Menschen die
da befragt worden sind in Deutschland
dem Fernsehen noch trauen und etwas über
40 Prozent den Leitmedien im Printmedien
und das sind natürlich erschreckende
Werte für eine Demokratie und das ist
ein großer Anlass aber wirklich großer
Anlass sich Sorgen zu machen und du hast
für dich recht die Berichterstattung
über die Krisen das fängt mit der
migrationskrise an und das auch bei der
corona-krise die haben wesentlich dazu
beigetragen dass das Vertrauen in den
Medien gefunden ist das kann man also
richtig grafisch sehen wie die Werte in
den Keller gegangen sind
aber warum ist das so Richard oder
anders lass mich mal vorne anfangen
Öffentlichkeit das ist ja das ist ja so
ein vieles davon ist ja so ein Gefühl
was ist eigentlich Öffentlichkeit was
braucht es um Öffentlichkeit
herzustellen was braucht es um um
wirkmächtig zu sein in einer
Öffentlichkeit um um etwas auszulösen um
ja überhaupt eine Öffentlichkeit
herzustellen und warum ist das so
wichtig
also ich sage immer Öffentlichkeit ist
wenn
gleiche über gleiches reden können ohne
gleicher Meinung sein zu müssen
das heißt also es gibt ja auch so so
großartige Rechtstexte wird über die
Rolle der Medien in der Öffentlichkeit
und so und da steht eigentlich immer
drin eine gut funktionierende
Öffentlichkeit wie eine liberale
Demokratie braucht das ja eine Diktatur
braucht keine gut funktionieren
Öffentlichkeit in Diktatur scheut eine
gut funktionierende Öffentlichkeit also
in den alten adelsgesellschaften oder in
den mittelalterlichen Gesellschaften
also wenn die Kirche eines nicht wollte
dann war das Öffentlichkeit ja es gab
nur das die Wahrheiten die die Kirche
verkündeten und darüber hinaus wurde
über nichts diskutiert
und die bürgerliche Gesellschaft in
ihren Anfängen besteht darin dass immer
mehr Leute lesen und schreiben können
das Zeitungen entstehen und dass sie
sich überregional austauschen können und
dass die Argumente nicht von vornherein
quasi zensiert werden oder nicht ernst
genommen sondern das überhaupt ein
Diskurs entsteht
und man kann sagen eine Öffentlichkeit
ist umso besser je mehr Leute sich aktiv
an ihr beteiligen können
und sie es umso besser je mehr diese
Impulse aufgegriffen und diskutiert
werden das heißt also dass das
Zauberwort dahinter ja ist so ein fieses
Wort das heißt die liberativ mit den die
bereits tief ist sondern so eine
Medienwissenschaften großes Wort und das
heißt übersetzt beratschlagend also je
mehr die Gesellschaft sich über die
wichtigen Dinge beratschlagt umso besser
ist es für eine liberale Demokratie das
ist der Kerngedanke und eine
funktionierende Öffentlichkeit muss eben
in diesem Sinne die liberativ sein muss
möglichst viele Meinungen aufnehmen sie
muss Meinung integrieren können nicht
ausgrenzen das sind alles sehr wichtige
Voraussetzungen damit eine Demokratie
funktioniert wenn wir sind uns ja einig
Demokratie ist wahrscheinlich die beste
Staatsform aber eben auch die fragilste
na wenn die Öffentlichkeit nicht richtig
funktioniert und die Leute das Vertrauen
in die Medien verlieren die ja
Vermittler sein sollen zwischen den
Menschen ja und der Politik
dann ist das ein schlimmer Befund und es
ist ganz ganz wichtig dass dagegen
gearbeitet wird lass uns darüber gleich
mal wirklich ernsthaft diskutieren aber
wann Nummer geschichtlich betrachtet
weil das sehr interessant ist wann
beginnt das ich habe dieser Tage gelesen
dass es eigentlich diese messestätte
Antwerpen Amsterdam aber Leipzig waren
wo es dann am ersten Tageszeitungen gab
worüber reden wir 17 Jahrhundert 18
Jahrhundert worüber reden wir ja genau
wir reden eigentlich so aus 18
Jahrhundert und das Spannende ist ja
bevor man diskutiert hat über
Menschenrechte oder über die Freiheit
des Handelns ja dass man tun kann was
man will weil die wichtigste Forderung
immer die Freiheit des Handels
das heißt das Bürgertum kommt ja an die
Macht durch die Freiheit des Handels je
mehr das Bürgertum handeln konnte umso
mehr Wohlstand kam es und zu mehr
Wohlstand es kam umso mehr viel im auf
wie wenig politische Beteiligung es
hatte
und das Interessante ist eben dass die
Zeitungen Zeitschriften eine Periodika
und so weiter vor allem in den
messestätten tatsächlich waren weil da
hat sich das Bürgertum getroffen und da
stand natürlich auch ganz wichtige Dinge
drin ja über Währungen über Preise über
güterknappheiten und so weiter damit
fing das tatsächlich alles mal an also
es fing wirklich mit der Wirtschaft an
und das übertrug sich dann auf andere
politische und gesellschaftliche Fragen
und deswegen spielen Zeitungen und
Zeitschriften seit dem 18 Jahrhundert
eine enorme Bedeutung um eine
bürgerliche Öffentlichkeit herzustellen
ich meine die Leute konnten ja nicht
fernsehen die Leute konnten nicht
telefonieren und die hatten jetzt über
diese Zeitung die Möglichkeit sich
überhaupt auszutauschen man kann sagen
ohne den
Journalismus der ist ja zunächst war
wäre eine bürgerliche Gesellschaft wie
die unsere überhaupt nicht entstanden
interessant das heißt Medien haben eine
wahnsinnig wichtige Rolle in dieser
Gesellschaft um demzufolge brauchen wir
wahnsinnige Verantwortung die da außer
wächst absolut und diese Verantwortung
ist ja auch wie gesagt juristisch
festgelegt ne da wo also drin steht was
ist die Aufgabe der Presse was ist die
Aufgabe des Fernsehens beim Fernsehen
ist es ja weil wir auch in
öffentlich-rechtliches Fernsehen haben
sie ja genau festgelegt das ist auch
diese Vermittlerfunktion haben soll es
hat unser Fernsehen hat
unterhaltungsfunktion es hat aber auch
ein Bildungsauftrag und so weiter das
sind ja alles Dinge die sich dieser
wichtigen Funktionen der Medien
verdanken
und das gleiche gilt im übrigen auch für
unsere Presse da gibt es auch den
Anspruch dass sie integrativ ist und
dass sie viele Meinungen einschließt und
dass man möglichst hohe Sachkompetenz
Informationen aufbereitet und so weil
wir weil man natürlich wusste als die
Bundesrepublik gegründet wurde ja dass
das alles unverzichtbar dafür ist damit
dieses Land funktioniert
so und jetzt hast du und das erlebe ich
zunehmend auch so im im Bekanntenkreis
jetzt hast du dieses Gefühl und das ist
mehr als nur ein Gefühl das
Medien nicht mehr richtig glaubwürdig
sind das Medien mit den sogenannten
Eliten unter einer Decke stecken du
erlebst plötzlich dieses Geraune auch
von jemandem wie Friedrich Merz den ich
sehr ernst nehme und der auf dem
Parteitag dann so ganz wie viel Sand die
die 58 Journalisten des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks begrüßt
und und sozusagen die ganze Zeit
andeutet da gibt es ein System das ist
dysfunktional geworden das funktioniert
nicht mehr so richtig das ist kein gutes
System mehr
und zunehmend alle glaubst du denn was
ja was glaubst du denn was Friedrich
Merz am öffentlichen so sehr
dysfunktional findet was meinst du stört
ihn da am meisten
weißt du dass ich tatsächlich genau
diese Frage stelle ich mir seitdem also
was ist eigentlich die wahre Motivation
hinter genau dieser Kritik findet man
kann da grundsätzlich kann man ganz
vieles kritisieren man kann sagen da
gibt es so Pensionen da gibt es zu viele
Menschen das ist alles zu das ist alles
so zu aufgeblähter fließt zu wenig
Eltern bekommen sollten sich im Grunde
genommen nicht mit ihrem
jobverwaltungsratener der zuständig ist
ihre Bezüge aushandeln dürfen und so
aber da ist das eine Kritik am
öffentlich-rechtlichen Jahr Funk oder
ist das eine Kritik ein sagen wir mal
naja so bestimmten Dingen wo man sagt er
das nicht mehr aktuell das kann man
deutlich besser machen so das ist doch
der Punkt das ist der redest du darüber
da redest du doch über über Management
Dinge Dinge die dringend geklärt werden
Dinge die in vielen Firmen auch sind
eigentlich bei den großen Dax-Konzernen
da über die Managergehälter und ist das
sind das eigentlich die richtigen und
geht das mit rechten Dingen zu so was
werden dafür Verträge gemacht was werden
dafür Abfindungen bezahlt warum Harmonie
selbst wenn die Firma miese macht also
solche Fragen sind genau und dann und
dann kann man und dann kann man zum
Beispiel auch mal darüber nachdenken
warum sind viele Systeme große Systeme
die sozusagen nicht rein
privatwirtschaftlich marktwirtschaftlich
organisiert sind irgendwann schwerfällig
und warum haben die diese Tendenz dass
sie irgendwann so so aufgebläht werden
und einfach gar nicht mehr beweglich
sind und man kann den Ball locker
zurückspielen das habe ich neulich auch
im Gespräch mit ihm gemacht ja immer der
der aktuelle deutsche Bundestag 734
glaube ich Abgeordnete so groß wie noch
nie Wolfgang Schäuble der seit vielen
vielen Jahren sagt wenn wir das nicht
hinkriegen diesen Bundestag mal zu
verkleinern ja eine echte Reform dann
können wir als Volksvertreter eigentlich
nicht mehr ernst genommen werden aber
wir kriegen es nicht auf die Reihe weil
wir es selber nicht wollen ja Systeme
tun sich schwer damit sich selber
sozusagen abzuschaffen ist ja gar keine
Frage aber deswegen noch mal die Frage
was was glaubst du denn was da wirklich
dahinter ist es gab ja schon mal für vor
langer Zeit
diesen Gedanken die ARD aufzulösen
Edmund Stoiber hatte das schon
vorgeschlagen und da reden wir jetzt
über die 90er Jahre das war so als der
siegeszucht des Privatfernsehens klar
war man sich gefragt hat wofür brauchen
wir noch ein gebührenfinanzierten
öffentlichen Rundfunk und würde das ZDF
jetzt nicht ausreichen warum braucht man
noch die ARD
und daran kann ich mich erinnern dass
diese Debatten heftig geführt wurden und
das war aber glaube ich zum Zeitpunkt
von Stoiber auch noch eine Zeit wo die
verschiedenen Rundfunkanstalten stark
politisch dominiert waren also der WDR
war links und der Bayerische Rundfunk
war war eher nicht links war er so gar
nicht links also Sigmund gottliebig
Leder links aufgefallen ja und früher
gab es eine ganze Riege Gabriele
chronisch Miles und bettnuts und so
weiter die also für für links sein im
Journalismus schlechthin standen das hat
sich ja heute massiv verändert das
könnte ja nicht mehr der Hauptvorwurf
sein dass also jetzt parteipolitisch
berichtet wird im jeweiligen Bundesland
oder sendergebiet und ich denke es ging
so ein bisschen darum dass man gedacht
hat dass die Dynamik die das
Privatfernsehen entfaltet eigentlich
ausreicht
und ich war damals immer schon auf der
Seite in den öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk zu verteidigen weil ich meine
die halbe Welt beneidet Deutschland um
den öffentlich-rechtlichen genau der
Punkt und das muss man mal ganz klar
sagen also jetzt frage ich mich mal in
welchem Land der Welt ist das Fernsehen
besser ja du kannst von der Seite sehen
und dann kann man sagen das war keine
schlechte Idee mit dem
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk das
heißt nicht dass man nicht bestimmte
Dinge im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
kritisieren kann es war auch gerade die
zum Beispiel die Frage die
Kontrollgremien die es gibt ja Fernseh
radverwaltungsrat und sowas alles wie
sind die eigentlich besetzt ist das noch
zeitgemäß kommt ihre Aufgabe
entsprechend nach ja solche Fragen die
kann man stellen aber das kratzt ja
nicht am Ende an der Architektur
öffentlich rechtlicher Rundfunk ja
sondern das sagt hier müssen vielleicht
mal ein paar Reformen her um
den Laden zeitgemäßer zu machen
und das für Nummer die Frage was ist die
Motivation dahinter ich ich musste
ehrlich sagen ich habe schon zur Zeiten
als ich noch beim beim Privatfernsehen
war ja ich kenne beide Systeme relativ
gut und ich habe schon zur Zeiten als
ich dort war habe ich ganz ganz viel
öffentlich-rechtliches Fernsehen
konsumiert
und das das hat vielerlei Gründe und
daran hat sich bis heute auch nichts
geändert und gerade auch weil ich zum
Beispiel das italienische Fernsehen
kenne ja schätze ich so sehr den
deutschen öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk und ich weiß welche Argumente
es gibt ja zu sagen was auch wir müssen
das jetzt anders machen wir schaffen die
Gebühren ab wir wir finanzieren das zum
Beispiel aus Steuermitteln wir machen
das alles kleiner und so weiter das ist
ja das was in Frankreich gerade der Weg
ist ich sage dir ich glaube wenn man mit
mit Leuten spricht die sich damit
auskennen sagen ja alle macht das nicht
mach das nicht in dem Moment wo du
anfängst das aus Steuermitteln zu
finanzieren dann ist es zwar sozusagen
offiziell erstmal von dieser
gebührengeschichte Weg aber dann wird es
noch undurchsichtiger dann dann werden
die Abhängigkeiten im Zweifel noch
größer und die ganze Sache wird noch
undurchschaubarer und deswegen ist das
kein guter Weg aber was mir auffällt ist
und das ist das ist sozusagen der der
Vorwurf den ich Friedrich Merz an dem
Punkt mache
dieses Geraune Boris Johnson mit der BBC
in England das gleiche gemacht in
Frankreich kommt dieser
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk unter
Druck in Italien gibt es die Debatte
auch jetzt haben wir es plötzlich auch
in Deutschland und ich denke oft sieht
die eigentlich nicht was in den USA
passiert wo so etwas überhaupt nicht
existiert und wenn man mit klugen Leuten
vom Spiegel zum Beispiel auch spricht
hinter den Kulissen
die sonst wenig Gefangene machen nicht
jetzt unter der Spiegel sondern
überhaupt viele Verlage die die immer
sagen wie es öffentlich-rechtliche
Rundfunk der gehört reformiert unter
streiten uns alle um den um den gleichen
oder denselben Werbekuchen und und die
kämpfen ja auch die die privaten Verlage
ich verstehe das alles und da wird auch
zu recht viel kritisiert aber hinter den
Kulissen sagen sie dir und viele sagen
es auch ganz offiziell wir können
trotzdem froh sein dass wir dieses
System haben ist ein ein sehr sehr gutes
Rundfunksystem dass wir in diesem Land
haben deswegen noch mal die wie
gefährlich ist dieses Geraune dass da
plötzlich in der Politik zu hören ist
und wie sehr hast du Richert jetzt auch
das Gefühl die Debatte die ihr beide
jetzt losgestoßen habt und Harald Welzer
dass sie sozusagen da vereinnahmt wird
von genau dieser Seite da kommt
plötzlich der Beifall genauerste Ecke
gesagt guck mal die sagen es jetzt da
wird einseitig berichtet da werden
bestimmte Meinungen nicht zugelassen es
ist alles ideologisch gefärbt also
aber so wird es jetzt vereinnahmt ja gut
ich habe das bislang noch nicht so
mitgekriegt und das ist immer das
Problem du kannst für alles was du
machst für jeder Äußerung Beifall an der
falschen Seite kriegen na also Sahra
Wagenknecht hat sich unlängst gefreut
dass sie von Björn höcke Beifall
gekriegt hat für bestimmte Äußerungen
ohne dass die beiden jetzt im selben
Boot sitzen also nur dagegen kann man
sich wahrscheinlich nie gänzlich
schützen aber das Ziel dessen was harald
Welzer und ich da ein Debatte angestoßen
haben das Ziel besteh auch darin die
Sachen besser zu machen und ich sie
abzuschaffen das ist doch ein riesiger
Unterschied das gleiche gilt ja auch für
die Printmedien auch unsere
printmedienlandschaft ist im
internationalen Vergleich eine der
besten finde ich auch wir müsste man
fragen welchem Land ist es denn besser
also ich habe ja mal für den
amerikanische Zeitung gearbeitet und das
noch in den seligen 90er Jahren kurz
bevor die große Zeitungskrise losging
man kann ja nicht sagen dass das
zeitungssystem in den USA besser ist und
man verglichen auf die Bevölkerungszahl
ja wie viele Qualitätszeitung hat es
denn damals in USA gegeben ja heute ist
die Situation noch schlimmer also das
ist auch was was ich verteidigen würde
und deswegen denke ich ja immer es ist
so wichtig dass unsere Qualitätspresse
Qualitätspresse bleibt ja also du kannst
es wenn du es zuspitzt sagen das ist die
Sorge eines Liebhabers ja der Angst hat
dass das Wasser bislang immer gut findet
wo die Hunde kommt und das ist im Grunde
genommen die Kritik und wenn ich was
kritisiere am öffentlich-rechtlichen
Fernsehen dem immer unter dem
Gesichtspunkt
ihr müsst aufpassen vor bestimmten
Tendenzen die Erde habt ja um das zu
bleiben was ja immer gewesen seid
das ist im Grunde genommen das Anliegen
und dass die teilweise genauso ich habe
nur
das ganz interessante wie das dann
vereinnahmt wird ich habe das eben ganz
bewusst auch so formuliert es gibt es
gibt dem Begriff Meute den ihr da in dem
Zusammenhang einmal benutzt kein
einziges Mal ja ich weiß war völlig zu
Recht würde ich immer verteidigen da
ging es um das zu Tode hetzen von
Christian Wulff in diesem Zusammenhang
ja also ich meine was was sind da für
niedere Instinkte in den
Redaktionsstuben hochgekommen jeder
wollte noch irgendein wichtiges Detail
hinzufügen was Christian Wulff als
Bundespräsident zu Fall bringt über
Bobby Car und Hotelrechnung und welche
klitze Kleinigkeiten da noch irgendwie
aufgefahren worden sind das sind
wirklich deswegen sage ich heute ja also
heute ist auch der richtige Eindruck ja
man denkt an das Wolfsrudel die
einlaufen vor und die anderen laufen
alle mit ja und jeder ist Teil dieses
dieser dieser Horror ja oder dieser
Meute
und nur in diesem einen einzigen
Zusammenhang benutzen wir dieses Wort
und da ist es auch völlig angebracht
denn das war genauso ein Verhalten
setzte dann in dem Moment ein und Harald
Welzer hat ja immer gesagt er war mal
Teil dieser Meute genau ja er sagt das
ja selbst er hat auch etwas so eine
sozialpsychologische Analyse gemacht
über Christian Wulff und das tut ihm
heute Leid ja weil es gibt ja auch so
ein bisschen die Regel dass jemand der
von allen angegriffen wird und wie wir
ja heute wissen eigentlich aufgrund von
kinkalitzieren ja dass man auf so
jemanden nicht auch noch eintritt aber
andere Begrifflichkeiten Informationen
unterdrücken einseitig berichten
Meinungen zensieren sich mit den
mächtigen gemein machen ich meine das
ist schon das ist eine das ist eine
klare Spur die man da liegt die ihr da
liegt
naja so wir untersuchen verschiedene
Tendenzen wo es Beispiele für alles das
gibt was du gesagt hast ein
Ausgangspunkt war ja wenn man sich mal
anschauen würde man würde zwei Stapel
ausdrucken einen Stapel ja
auf dem die Berichterstattung ist die
die Lieferung von schweren Waffen an die
Ukraine ablehnt und ein Stapel
derjenigen die von der Regierung fordern
mehr Waffen zu liefern
dann käme bei dem einen 1 cm bei raus
und bei dem anderen Thema ein toben raus
der passt in kein Zimmer ja das ist und
das interessant und das ist natürlich
eine es ist ich weiß es ist die ein oder
andere kritische Stimme zu Wort gekommen
wir beide haben eins zu eins darüber
diskutieren
gemacht ist auch wunderbar ist aber eine
ziemliche Ausnahme und das ist etwas
einseitiges weil wir ja aus dem
Bevölkerungsumfragen wissen dass da die
Meinung eher fifty fifty ist oder eine
leichte Tendenz für Waffe Lieferung das
heißt also dass die öffentliche Meinung
und die veröffentlichte Meinung hier
sehr sehr weit auseinander gehen und das
macht einem natürlich Sorgen das ist ein
total interessanter Punkt Richard in dem
wir gerade sind ich habe darüber lange
nachgedacht und ich bin wirklich jetzt
vielleicht nicht überraschen rezidiert
und komplett anderer auffassen wenn ich
jetzt gespannt wie du das begründen
willst pass auf das Argument ist
folgendes und ich glaube es ist ein ganz
gutes Argument ich habe mich gefragt
welche Öffentlichkeiten gibt es
eigentlich es gibt sozusagen eine
öffentliche Meinung
das ist sagen wir mal
es gibt eine Meinung unter Experten das
nennen wir B und dann gibt es die
veröffentlichte Meinung das ist
sozusagen C und nach meiner Auffassung
besteht der große Denkfehler darin zu
glauben dass es zwischen a und c eine
Zusammenhang geben muss der du meinst
zwischen B und C nein zwischen a und c
die ganz normale öffentliche Meinung
wenn Du Dir mal anschaust worum es
wirklich geht was ist sozusagen das was
wir bitte ich habe mich Journalismus
studiert ich bin kein Medientheoretiker
und du hast das bestimmt alles
philosophisch durchdrungen habe ich ich
argumentiere jetzt aus meiner ganz
praktischen täglichen Arbeit heraus
meiner täglichen praktischen Arbeit und
nicht nur meiner sondern in der meiner
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und so weiter
ist es doch so
dass wir auf der Suche Ukraine Krieg wir
sind auf der Suche nach Menschen die uns
kompetent etwas dazu sagen können
das heißt du landest am Ende immer
automatisch bei ExpertInnen überraschend
viele militär-expertinnen und
Militärexperten die dann zu Wort kommen
warum weil doch unser Auftrag auch ist
Menschen zu fragen die von der Materie
etwas verstehen und ich habe mich
gefragt ich habe das glaube ich mal
erzählt ich habe mit 14 Jahren habe ich
angefangen als tellerwischer zu arbeiten
in so einem riesigen Restaurant und habe
mich dann so über zwei Jahre langsam
hochgearbeitet und mit 16 stand ich dann
dort hinter der Bar hinter dem Tresen im
Sommer und hat dann dort so Leute
bedient die relativ gut drauf waren und
mit fortschreitender Tageszeit immer
besser drauf waren weil sie sich ein
Gläschen nach dem anderen von mir haben
servieren lassen und ich weiß doch das
war sehr interessant ich habe mir immer
dieses die geschwaller da von diesen
Leuten die vor dem Tresen saßen angehört
die sich gegenseitig die Welt erklärt
haben und dabei so unfassbar viel
Dünnschiss verbreitet haben das kann man
sich gar nicht vorstellen es war
verbaler Durchfall um es mal sozusagen
und das war der Moment in dem ich damals
mit 16 Jahren angefangen habe die
Süddeutsche Zeitung zu lesen warum weil
ich wissen wollte wie es wirklich ist
das ist der Grund warum sozusagen nach
meiner Meinung in Zeitungen aber auch im
Fernsehen reden Menschen und kommen
Menschen zu Wort und zu Recht zu Wort
die etwas von dem verstehen was gerade
Gegenstand von Berichterstattung ist und
eben nicht die suffköpfe die bei mir
vorm Tresen saßen gut das ist der
entscheidende Punkt habe ich verstanden
und jetzt jetzt gebe ich dir bei diesem
Punkt erstmal grundsätzlich weitgehend
Recht
geben weil es natürlich müssen die
Impulse die von den Menschen kommen in
reflektierter Form irgendwo auftauchen
vielleicht nicht in unre also man kann
sich sozusagen nicht völlig Entfernen
von dem was die Menschen denken aber ich
verstehe völlig dass man sich auf
Expertise verlässt jetzt kommt viele
viel umfassendere Kritik von mir ich
bezweifle die Expertise und ich kann ja
auch sagen warum du bist
Expertise der Experten und jetzt gebe
ich dir auch mehrere Gründe dafür du
hast von den Militärs gesprochen die
haben eine hohe militärische Expertise
die wir beide nicht haben und die auch
die allermeisten Journalisten von ganz
wenigen Ausnahmen abgesehen nicht haben
das beleuchtet aber nur die militärische
Seite
außerdem sind diese Militärs auch nicht
zwangsläufig unabhängige Experten sonst
sind im Regelfall NATO Militärs und so
weiter das heißt sie sind sozusagen
eingebunden in eine Partei die hier in
diesem Krieg eine Rolle spielt
sie sind nicht einsame Dinge in ihren
Stuben
und das zweite gilt erst recht für diese
anderen ExpertInnen diese
militärexpertinnen von denen es ja viele
gibt und die häufigsten sind ja auch
tatsächlich viele Frauen bei die in
transatlantischen Instituten arbeiten
die erzählen mir ganz genau was putin
will und was Putin denkt und die haben
nie mit Putin geredet die waren
vielleicht in ihrem Leben nur
vereinzelte Male in Russland wo die ganz
oft waren es in Washington das heißt sie
kennen sehr sehr genau die amerikanische
Sichtweise und ist auch legitim die
amerikanische Sichtweise zu vertreten
Einspruch aber dass das jetzt Leute sind
die ganz ganz genau und unabhängig und
unparteilich auf diesen Konflikt gucken
daran habe ich gewisse Zweifel wirklich
Einspruch also ich könnte die jetzt aus
dem Stand mehrere nennen Sabine
fischereis nur eine und andere die ganz
ganz viel Zeit auch selbst in Osteuropa
verbracht haben die teils in Russland
und in der Ukraine gelebt haben die sehr
genau diese Systeme verstehen und weißt
du mein Punkt ist ein anderer
Mittelpunkt ist der Richard mein Punkt
ist der wenn Experten und und da habe
ich auch ein Problem sozusagen mit der
These dass da einseitig berichtet wird
wenn wir Experten fragen das ist
sozusagen der nächste gedankliche
Schritt den man da machen muss wenn wir
die Leute fragen die sich damit
auskennen und wenn diese Leute sagen das
ist ja sehr interessant die waren ja von
Anfang an haben viele von denen und das
wir reden von der ersten Kriegswoche als
der Angriff auf Kiew gescheitert war
seit dem Zeitpunkt der lebe ich sehr
konsistent wie diese Leute sagen
interessant das ist jetzt schief
gegangen da haben wir offensichtlich die
Stärke dieser russischen Armee falsch
eingeschätzt und jetzt lass uns mal
gucken was daraus wirklich noch wird und
die haben von Anfang an die Möglichkeit
den Betracht gezogen dass wir den
Ukrainern wenn wir Ihnen entsprechend
beistehen durchaus Möglichkeiten an die
geben können ihre Art zu leben ihre
Freiheit ihr Land am Ende verteidigen
können
und ich will aber nur sagen wenn wenn
diese Leute zu dieser Meinung kommen und
Medien berichten darüber dann ist das
sozusagen nicht das Problem der Medien
und dann ist das auch nicht die
schultermedien sondern ist das etwas was
wir einfach schlicht und ergreifend
abbilden und in diesem Fall war es
überraschenderweise so dass ich viele
dieser Experten überraschend einig waren
und nichts anderes hat Medien
Wirklichkeit abgebildet und und das ist
der Grund warum ich an dem Punkt mit
diesem Thema mit diesen mit denen
überhaupt nicht mit ja ich verstehe
deine Argumentation jetzt kannte ich
natürlich sagen warum sind die sich alle
so einig du würdest sagen weil sie
Experten sind weil sie sich so
wahnsinnig gut auskennen ja aber wir
reden hier über etwas
wo es keine Expertise gibt ich sage dir
nur die Beispiele wo es keine gibt ja es
gibt eine Expertise über die Frage was
kann man mit welchem Panzer wie wo
machen und so ja was ist taktisch kluger
militärischer Schachzug da gibt es genug
expertise
aber es gibt keinerlei expertise in der
Frage was Putin mit diesem Krieg
eigentlich wollte da gibt es zehn
verschiedene Meinungen
es gibt keinerlei expertise in der Frage
mal gesetz den Fall ist gelänge der
Ukraine tatsächlich die Russen wieder
aus der Ukraine rauszudrängen was wir
uns alle wünschen ja auch die Krim
vielleicht zurückzubekommen was Russland
dann macht ja also wird Putin dann
gestürzt werden die Russen Chemiewaffen
oder Bio-Waffen einsetzen kommt
tatsächlich taktische Atomwaffen beiden
hat ja vor kurzem noch mal appelliert an
Putin das nicht zu tun weil die
amerikanische diese Möglichkeit für denk
behalten ja ich meine wenn die
Amerikaner diese Möglichkeit für denkbar
halten sollten unsere Experten das auch
für eine denkbare Möglichkeit halten
dann sollten die das auch in ihre
Vorstellungen dass die Ukraine die
Gebiete zurückerobert mit einbeziehen
das ist etwas das finde ganz wenig statt
und dann frage ich mich immer
ist bei den Experten dann nicht auch
häufig Wunschdenken steht das nicht im
Mittelpunkt muss man nicht auch die
Expertise von Experten mit guten
Argumenten anzweifeln können müsste sich
das in unseren Medien nicht stärker
abbilden nee ich ich nenne den ein
anderes Beispiel Richard lass uns doch
mal ganz kurz bei diesem Punkt bleiben
weil ich finde diese die Wirklichkeit
den Medien abgebildet ist ich glaube die
muss man irgendwie klarer und sauberer
definieren ich ich bezweifle ganz massiv
das ist die Aufgabe sozusagen von Medien
ist genau das immer paritätisch
abzubilden dass er häufig eine Argument
dass das du auch oft benutzt zu sagen da
gibt es aber draußen eine eine
Öffentlichkeit die sagt zur Hälfte pro
Waffenlieferung und die andere das
müssen wir nicht das müssen asymmetrisch
nein nein nein nein Sie müssen nicht
eins zu eins immer genau proportional
gut schreiben was die Menschen genau das
ist aber etwas also was viele Leute gut
aber gut ganz klar
einer Meinung wenn weil wenn es dir
massiv ist davon entfernt dann muss man
darüber nachdenken wie kommt es dazu ich
sage du würdest sagen es kommt deswegen
dazu weil die Experten die Dinge anders
sehen und ich habe gerade gesagt auch
die Experten leben in einer bestimmten
Welt okay ich habe
repräsentativ abgegangen Gegenargument
Richard wie viele Kreationisten laufen
durch Amerika wie viele Amerikaner
glauben dass Frauen aus der Rippe
irgendeines großartigen Mannes gebastelt
worden ehrlich gesagt weiß ich das nicht
wirklich aber es gibt ziemlich viele
davon genau 40 50 Prozent je nachdem
wenn du Fragen das müssen die Medien
nicht abbilden so das ist der Punkt das
sagen die aber auch die sagen pass mal
auf wir sind eine Wirklichkeit die
Evangelikalen in den USA sind 70 80
Millionen Menschen aber das ist ja
erwiesenermaßen falsch also hier geht es
darum man muss nicht ja erwiesenermaßen
komplett irre oder falsche Dinge medial
repräsentiert so gebe ich sofort her
Klimawandel
Klima Leugner nicht proportional zu Wort
kommen lassen weil es objektiver
Schwachsinn aber wenn 60% der Amerikaner
Richard glauben dass es den Klimawandel
nicht gibt haben diese Leute dann nicht
an der Rechte darauf mit ihrer Meinung
abgebildet zu werden die die würden
immer sagen selbstverständlich haben wir
das also selbstverständlich komplett
Objektiv widerlegte komplett sachlich
falsche Dinge müssen nicht repräsentativ
dargestellt werden wenn wir über die
Waffenlieferung reden dann reden wir
über die Ängste in der Bevölkerung
Menschen die Angst haben dass das Ganze
doch noch zu einem Atomkrieg eskaliert
oder das ist zumindestens für die
Ukraine ja ein ein atomares
Bedrohungsszenario gibt was sich in
grausigen Schrecken verwandeln kann das
ist Menschen gibt die wissen dass die
Russen wahrscheinlich nicht tatenlos
zusehen werden wenn sie konventionell
dabei sind die Krieg zu verlieren die
Angst haben vor den Folgen die das haben
können das alles sind keine objektiv
falsifizierten Dinge sondern das sind
sehr ernstzunehmende nicht von allen
Behälter aber sehr ernstzunehmende
Befürchtung und die müssen sich
wiederfinden aber hast du nicht das
Gefühl dass die sich wiederfinden ich
habe zu keinem Zeitpunkt in einem
Verhältnis 1 zu 100 finden die sich
wieder
das würde ich wirklich so nicht sagen
Richard ich bin ich bin auch ich bin
auch weiter von entfernt jetzt dieses
gibt ja man merkt das auch und da bist
du ja auch gerade sehr im Fokus
irgendwie ein denke immer an wie das ist
nicht in Ordnung weil ich finde jemand
der der zu Recht davor warnt und sagt
was auf was wird so eine Atommacht
machen wenn sie wirklich mit dem Rücken
zur Wand steht was kann da alles noch
daraus erwachsen jemand der zu Recht
darauf hinweist dem muss man nicht
irgendwie vorführen und ihm die ganze
Zeit erklären dass er sich jetzt geirrt
hat so dieses triumphialistische Geheule
also ja leider noch lange gar nicht zu
Ende so das ist der Punkt und ich bin
also wir sind uns doch eigentlich ich
wünsche mir genauso wie wie du dir das
wünschst ja dass die Russen aus der
Ukraine rauskommen meine Angst ist nur
dass das auf militärische Art und Weise
selbst wenn es jetzt ne also rein
kriegstechnisch funktionieren sollte am
Ende zu noch schrecklicheren Folgen
führen können das stimmt die muss man
leider realistisch einkalkulieren also
die zweitstärkste
der Macht der Welt für die wir sie
bislang gehalten haben und als diese
sich überhaupt nicht herausstellt im
Augenblick ja die ihrem
Selbstverständnis nach mindestens
militärisch eine Großmacht ja beseelt
von viel weiterreichenden
großmachtsfantasien wenn so ein Land ja
wenn man dem vorführt dass es nicht mal
die Ukraine besiegen kann das ist nicht
mal seine passiert das macht mir riesige
Angst und ich finde diese Angst wird
nicht adäquat ausgedrückt ich meine der
der entscheidende Punkt ist doch was wir
erleben ist einer der größten
Öllieferanten der Welt ist nicht in der
Lage seine eigenen Panzer zu betanken
das ist das was wir gerade erleben ja
wir erleben einen ein wirklich
verheerendes Chaos und ich frage mich
auch übrigens und du dich wahrscheinlich
auch
ich habe natürlich am Anfang des Krieges
auf die militärische Expertise gehört
und diese militärische Expertise die war
von wenigen Ausnahmen abgesehen unisono
dass dieser Krieg maximal ein paar
Wochen dauert und dass die Russen Haus
hoch überlegen sind und dann ist aber
die frage mich wie konnten denn die
militärischen Experten so wenig Ahnung
haben denn lange bevor die
internationale Gemeinschaft also gemeint
sind ja vor allen Dingen Amerikaner und
europäische Länder im großen Stil Waffen
geliefert haben bei der Krieg ja schon
vorher ins Stocken geraten ja es ist
richtig aber die Frage ist Richard und
deswegen nehmen auch die Frage an dich
was und du hast damals ist auch so ein
Zitat das gerade die Runde gemacht hat
natürlich hat die Ukraine ein Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung aber auch die Pflicht
zu Klugheit einzusehen weil man sich ja
geben muss dessen Satz den du gesagt
hast das ist ein Satz den ich gegeben
habe zu dem man zwei Sachen sagen muss
das eine ist eben alles unter der
damaligen militärischen Expertise dass
die Ukraine den Krieg schnell verliert
das darf man nicht vergessen das war der
Hintergrund der Aussage weil die war ja
objektiv falsch nee die ist nicht
objektiv falsch es ist ja keine
Sachaussage
sondern es ist eine Aussage eine
Aufforderung eine Aufforderung ja und
die Frage ist
Markus wir wissen leider leider leider
überhaupt noch nicht wie dieser Krieg
ausgeht
es kann mit einer kleinen
Wahrscheinlichkeit zu einem positiven
Ende kommen ja das ist tatsächlich
gelingt innerhalb von einem halben Jahr
oder so die Russen so weit
zurückzudrängen dass sie einsehen dass
sie das nicht halten können
es gibt aber auch viele andere
Wahrscheinlichkeiten zu denen eben
gehört dass die Russen andere Mittel
einsetzen als die die sie bisher
eingesetzt haben weil sie über
eskalationsdominanz verfügen das heißt
also sie können noch fürchterliche
menschenverachtende Waffen einsetzen der
Punkt ist am Ende und das ist das
schreckliche daran es gibt den
kirke-gorsatz weil das Leben kann nur
vorwärts gelebt und nur vom Ende her
verstanden werden
und am Ende wenn dieser Krieg mal
tatsächlich vorbei sein sollte wann auch
immer das ist dann wird man wissen ja ob
das was man getan hat richtig war oder
falsch in der Situation kann man das
nicht genau wissen weil wir nicht wissen
wohin dieser Krieg noch führt das macht
die Sache so schwierig wir fischen bei
dieser Sache im Trüben wir irren dir
vorwärts wir wissen es nicht genau und
deswegen und da kommen die zu meinem
Ausgangspunkt hinzu müssen solche
Gespräche wie wir beide die hier führen
ja wo wir in
vollem Respekt vor dem Gesprächspartner
und in voller an Planung seiner
redlichen Motivation und im durchdenken
seiner Argumente über diese Dinge
diskutieren und ich wünsche mir dass das
viel mehr in den deutschen Medien der
Fall aber weißt du welchen Ergebnis am
Ende auch immer die Politik kommen aber
weißt du was ich ich auch da wieder ne
ich habe wirklich also ich bin der
letzte der sich einer einer Medienkritik
stellt und ich ich sehe oder nicht
stellt ja und ich ich
sehe ganz viele Dinge kritisch ich sehe
unseren Hang sozusagen zur kurzen
schnellen Schlagzeile zu schnellen
Überschrift ich sehe unseren Hang Dinge
zu verkürzen ich sehe unseren Hang Dinge
aus dem Kontext zu reißen ich sehe
unseren Hang sozusagen von einer
Sensation
zunächst und zu schippern ich sehe
unseren Hang auch mit Blick auf unsere
eigene Sendung zum Beispiel dann mit mit
Genuss jemandem eine Aussage wieder
vorzuspielen vorzuhalten die ja
vielleicht mal drei vier Monate
zurückliegen in der eigenen Sendung
möglicherweise getätigt hat also ich
sehe dieses System den man vorwerfen
kann ein sich selbst erhaltenes System
zu sein ich sage lieber auch Richard und
und das ist jetzt mein Punkt es gibt
natürlich auch diese andere Dimension es
gibt ganz hervorragenden großartigen
Journalismus und wenn ich am Anfang mich
als Steinbrecher zitiert habe der sagt
diese Studie hat ergeben dass gerade in
der corona-pandemie die Glaubwürdigkeit
von Medien gelitten hat ich gehe noch
einen Schritt zurück ich glaube dass in
der großen migrationskrise in der
flüchtlingskrise 2015 da hat es einen an
einen echten eine echte harte Narbe
gegeben an dem Punkt da ist ganz viel
Glaubwürdigkeit verloren gegangen was
glaubst du eigentlich was glaubst du
eigentlich genau wodurch also was meinst
du hätten die Medien falsch gemacht ja
es gibt ja auch Untersuchungen dazu die
zum Beispiel sagen dass Medien sehr
lange auch den Merkel Satz wir schaffen
das war relativ kritiklos übernommen
haben das ist ja interessant ehrlich das
haben sie aber nicht lange aber nicht
lange eine ganze Weile
zu sagen ich würde sagen drei vier
Monate aber nicht länger ja dann kam die
Kölner Silvester Nacht und so weiter ja
dann dann war das jemand ganz anderes
dann gibt er das Thema plötzlich in eine
andere Richtung vorher schon gekippt ne
und die Silvesternacht war dann der
Brandbeschleuniger also genau aber wenn
du dich erinnerst es gab die die
Schlagzeile in der Zeit ne willkommen ja
also sozusagen diese diese
Willkommenskultur ich meine dass das
selbst die Bild-Zeitung gemacht hätte
wenn ich wirklich sagen aber ich
erinnere mich ja ich muss muss man daran
erinnern es war Sigmar Gabriel der mit
einem
bild-button refugees welcome im
Deutschen Bundestag gesessen hat
und das war war dann und das ist halt
interessant
ich glaube schon dass Medien dann auch
durchaus erstmal
voranirrend das war auch ein Ukraine
Krieg so das war in der corona-pandemie
so aber
Entschuldigung der Medien erst einmal
sagen ne es gab für diese Krisen kein
Script das meine ich das heißt keiner
wusste ja wie er sich zu verhalten halte
ich gerade hin und keiner konnte die
Dinge realistisch einschätzen wir
wussten am Anfang der Migration als sie
Willkommenskultur als der Begriff
geboren wurde genau ja war noch nicht
klar wie viele Menschen über die
Balkanroute nach Deutschland kommen und
wer alles nach Deutschland kommt wer
kein syrischer Flüchtling ist das war zu
dem Zeitpunkt nicht klar am Anfang von
Corona war überhaupt nicht einzuschätzen
wie gefährlich das ist oder sein würde
ja hier beim Krieg haben wir eine
ähnliche Situation ja das eine solche
Situationen wie den brutalen russischen
Überfall auf die Ukraine den hatte
offensichtlich von sehr wenigen fällten
abgesehen überhaupt keine ernsthaft
vorhergesehen und auch hier gab es kein
Skript genau und das Merkwürdige ist
wenn man kein Skript hat dann neigt man
dazu seine Meinung den anzupassen die
die anderen auch haben du würdest sagen
der Expertenmeinung ich würde sagen eher
so journalistisches Schwarmverhalten und
dann entstehen quasi so sehr schnell
Journalismus
genau so öffnen öffentliche öffentliche
mehrheitsströmungen den man sich anpasst
im sicheren Gewässer Impfpflicht ist ein
gutes Beispiel dafür ne der Impfpflicht
ist für mich deswegen gutes Beispiel
weil das eigentlich immer klar war in
Deutschland dass wir keine Impfpflicht
einführen werden und es gab wie also wir
da unter Experten jetzt kann man ja mal
sagen weder unter Experten noch unter
der Normalbevölkerung dafür eine
Mehrheit und dann gab es dieses im
Herbst Winter diese starke Anschwellen
der Infektionszahlen und plötzlich kippt
ihr die Stimmung ja also ähnlich
silvestern
auf einmal waren die gleichen
Medienvertreter die vorher gegen eine
Impfpflicht waren enorm dafür
dass man seine Meinung wechselt ist
normal wenn man Menschen ihre Meinung
nicht wechseln haben sie nicht mehr alle
also man muss natürlich wenn man neue
Informationen bekommt die hier
einspeisen ne in seinen meinungssystem
aber wenn man dann diejenigen
beschuldigt oder ausgrenzt die anderer
Meinung sind dann wird das problematisch
ja mit das stört mich das stört mich
jemand der selber seine Meinung geändert
hat alle die nicht immer genau die
gleiche Meinung haben für schwachsinnig
erklärt aber hier kommt das und dann
ging die Zahlen wieder runter da sollte
die Impfpflicht eingeführt werden ja
Olaf Scholz auch ein schönes Beispiel
völlig gegen die Impfpflicht völlig
dafür ja und am Ende froh dass sie nicht
gekommen ist und jedes Mal aber immer
dieser Druck auf diejenigen die gerade
eine andere Meinung haben als da wo der
Cursor des gefühlten Anstandes ist und
das ist ein Problem und damit das ist
meine feste Überzeugung damit verspielt
mein Vertrauen ich weiß nicht aber auch
da sage ich dir ne es lohnt ein
genauerer Blick so ich will mich da
jetzt nicht irgendwie so sagen besonders
rausnehmen überhaupt gar nicht ich habe
immer im im Fernsehen ganz klipp und
klar gegen ein Impfpflicht orientiert
und das heißt bis heute und zwar mit der
simplen Begründung dass man nicht vor
einer Bundestagswahl eine Impfpflicht
ausschließen kann um sie nach der
Bundestagswahl einführen zu wollen das
geht allein deswegen funktioniert das
nicht und deswegen war ich immer
dezidiert dagegen aber ich will ihn nur
einen Punkt sagen Richard ich habe mich
niemals von irgendjemandem deswegen
unter Druck gesetzt fühlt gefühlt ich
durfte das immer laut sagen ich bin
niemals dafür angegriffen worden keine
hat mich deswegen fertig gemacht es gab
keinen keinen Journalismus der mir
deswegen irgendwie vorgeworfen hat
leichtfertig zu sein sondern die Leute
sind diesem Argument durchaus gefolgt
wir haben noch ein anderes Beispiel ja
aber du bist du bist in der Geschichte
ja nicht das Opfer ja aber Svenja
flaßpöhler die bei Plasberg in der
Sendung war und da also von vier Leuten
gleichzeitig angegriffen wurde die
plötzlich ruckartig ihre Meinung in
Richtung ebenpflicht geändert hatte das
ist ein anderes Beispiel
ja was wir also jetzt mal unabhängig
davon ich habe diese diese Sendung
damals nicht gesehen aber Svenja
flaßpöhler die wir beide gut kennen ist
sowieso kein Opfern ne doch in dieser
Welt nicht nein ja also Meinung stark
sie ist eine starke Frau ja aber es war
in dem Moment was ja nicht nur so dass
sie in der Talkshow angegriffen worden
ist das gibt's in Talkshows 4 gegen 1
war keine glückliche Besetzung das muss
man wirklich sagen weil sie hat die
geltende Rechtsposition verteidigt aber
sie ist dann nachher auch noch in den
Printmedien massiv angegriffen worden
also nicht nur in die üblichen
Shitstorms in den sozialen Medien
sondern auch in den Leitmedien und das
hat am Ende dazu geführt ich hatte sie
als Gast in meiner Sendung und zwar
bezeichneter Weise wurde unsere Sendung
aufgezeichnet an dem gleichen Tag wo sie
abends behaart aber fair war
und wir haben über überhaupt nicht übers
impfen gesprochen wir haben über ihr
Buch gesprochen ja und die die These die
sie darin hat das sagt das ist gut dass
unsere Gesellschaft immer sensibler
werden aber es ist schlecht wenn sie
deswegen immer intoleranter werden
richtig das war ihre These und dann gab
es eine Kritik unserer Sendung die nach
der hart aber fair-sendung ausgestrahlt
wurde in der Frankfurter Allgemeinen
Sonntagszeitung wo nur vom Impfen die
Rede war was überhaupt gar kein Thema in
unserer Sendung war und die Journalistin
hat sich das muss man mal sagen nicht
entblödet zu sagen sie sagen es nicht
aber sie denken es
ich sag mal in welchem Land leben wir
also so jemand der doch gegen jegliche
Regeln der Professionalität in dem
Moment verstößt indem er Menschen
unterstellt dass sie etwas denken was
sie nicht sagen also ich muss sagen das
war ein absoluter Tiefpunkt des
deutschen journalismuses und ich habe
mich schon gewundert dass Julia Enke
dann weiterhin verirrtum Chefin da
geblieben ist also das war wirklich ein
totaler Tiefpunkt es kann da kann man
nicht machen ein mehr von
Unterstellungen mir ist ja auch falls
Balance vorgeworfen worden wenn es dich
irgendwie an das an das Gespräch auf dem
Podium der Zeit mit mit Jan Böhmermann
zum Beispiel weil wir immer mal wieder
jemanden wie Hände gestrickt zu Gast
haben ja und da kann ich mich auch
erinnern ja und dagegen habe ich mich
damals auch massiv gewehrt und ich ich
habe das aber weder ja noch irgendjemand
anderem jemals in irgendeiner Form übel
genommen sondern ich dachte gut ja
direkt in dem Gespräch gut ausgekommen
ja Rede und Gegenrede und damit kann ich
leben ich will dir noch ein zum Beispiel
sagen Corona ich ich habe in dem
Zusammenhang weil das Gefühl entsteht
sozusagen da verbünden sich die Medien
mit denen da oben um man darf ja nicht
mehr so richtig sagen und da wird ja
nicht mehr richtig berichtet und so
weiter
ich verstehe woher dieses Gefühl kommt
ich
habe das vorher nach ausgeführt warum
Medien nach meinem Dafürhalten zu
bestimmten Meinungen kommen wir können
ja nichts anderes tun als uns sozusagen
bei den richtigen Leuten zu informieren
und ich halte es ehrlich gesagt auch für
meine Pflicht das ist nach meiner
Auffassung der Job von Qualitätsmedien
ist genau das im Gegensatz sozusagen zu
den direktmedien wie ihr sie nennt
Twitter Facebook und andere wo einfach
jeder sozusagen
ungeprüft irgendetwas erzählen kann
häufig auch richtig ist aber häufig eben
auch falsches man weiß es manchmal nicht
so genau teilweise dubiose Quellen und
so weiter aber die Aufgabe von
Qualitätsmedien ist es dahinter zu
gucken oder genau hin zu gucken da sind
wir und diese Meinung genau bildet man
sich vor allem mit Hilfe von Experten
ich will ja auch eines zu sagen ergänzen
es ist üblich wenn du bei Twitter ja nur
eine bestimmte kleine Zeichenzahl zur
Verfügung hast und Twitter wird eben
nicht journalistisch reagiert um geprüft
und so weiter da haust du in deiner
Meinung raus und wenn dir die Meinung
einer Person nicht gefällt dann greifst
du die Person als Ganzes an ja sagst was
das denn für einen Schwachmat oder Idiot
oder so total persönlich und das finden
wir heute in den Leitmedien also in dem
Printmedien über die ich gesprochen habe
viel viel häufiger als früher so kannst
du aber keine guten sachbezogenen
Debatten mehr führen das heißt also die
Auseinandersetzung muss auch um die
Argumente gehen und nicht darum Menschen
als ganze moralisch zu diskreditieren
weil sie anderer Meinung sind als du sie
hast
und das ist etwas was sie Leitmedien
niemals tun dürfen aber viel zu oft
inzwischen tun und ich hoffe dass diese
Debatte jetzt dazu beiträgt dass das
zurückgefahren wird weil dann trauen
sich irgendwann die Leute nicht mehr
ihre Meinung zu sagen und das wäre das
schlimmste was in einer Demokratie
passieren kann ja das ist wahr und ich
ich ermuntere auch immer Leute ihre
Meinung zu sagen ich will aber noch mal
einen Punkt machen ich habe nur ganz zum
Schluss und ganz schnell die Frage die
sich mir auch immer wieder stellt ist
konsumieren wir Medien möglicherweise
mittlerweile auf eine ja zum Teil
falsche Art und Weise also wir geben uns
sozusagen so schnell zufrieden mit so
einer halben Überschrift und und halten
das dann für Fakten und sind nicht
bereit und haben auch nicht die Zeit und
nehmen uns auch nicht die Zeit uns
wirklich mal intensiv mit Dingen
auseinanderzusetzen weil wenn man
wirklich mal anfängt zu tauchen dann
findet man auch die Perlen in den
sogenannten gleichfamilien das man
findet sie und ich nenne ihn gutes
Beispiel gerade sozusagen die die es
gibt diese diesen die diese
Debatte rund um die
migrationskrise 2015 und und ein Beleg
dafür dass ich sozusagen Medien
vermeintlich gemein gemacht haben mit
der Politik ist diese Titelseite der
Zeit willkommen ja die die
Willkommenskultur die praktisch überall
dann zu lesen war aber in derselben Zeit
habe ich Wochen später ein großartiges
Stück gelesen von einer
Korrespondentin die lange Zeit ein paar
kleinere Gemeinden in Sachsen im
Erzgebirge begleitet hat ist immer
wieder dahin und hat die einen
afd-politiker und auch eine langjährige
CDU-Abgeordnete beide immer wieder
begleitet
und da taucht dieser afd-abgeordnete auf
ich meine es war ein Mann der sagt guck
mal wie das hier läuft da gibt es diese
kleinen Gemeinden da oben im Erzgebirge
und die fordern seit Jahren an der
Anbindung an öffentlichen Busverkehr und
dieser Bus kommt nicht dann kommt 2015
es werden geflüchtete Menschen aus
Syrien Irak werden dort auch unter
anderem untergebracht und was kommt
wenig später die Busverbindung die
Geschichte geht noch weiter irgendwann
werden die Leute sich denn in dem Auto
jetzt darüber gefreut oder die haben
sich erstmal darüber gefreut dann werden
irgendwann diese Unterkünfte geschlossen
weil die Menschen die dort untergebracht
waren vielleicht woanders hingezogen
sind oder woanders untergebracht werden
mussten wie auch immer was ist das erste
was passiert der Bus verschwindet wieder
frage ich zwar ja also
und jetzt denkst du das ist so eine
schöne AFD Geschichte und das spielt den
natürlich total Indikator ich kann mir
vorstellen die CDU-Abgeordnete die dann
wenig später auch dass Mandat verliert
gegen genau diesen Mann
bestätigt das und sagt es war genauso
und jetzt stellt sich raus in diesen
Dörfern wählte einen Großteil AFD und
ich denke dann immer okay und das war
auch die Frage der der Autorin die das
dort beschrieben hat sind die jetzt
wirklich alle rechts oder haben die
Probleme mit dem Bus
ist das also Ausdruck sozusagen des
Protests gegen genau diese diese
Geschichte oder sind die wirklich alle
rechtsradikal ich ich kann das immer
total ich kann ja ich kann hier nur
eines sagen ich habe immer die
Überzeugung vertreten dass nicht jeder
der AFD wird rechtsradikale genau das
ist mein Sohn ich halte das auch für ein
unter anderem medial befeuertes Klischee
und es ist wenn 10% der Bevölkerung die
Meinung der AFD haben dann wollen wir
nicht unterstellen das 10% der
Bevölkerung Nazis sind genau auch wenn
Nazis bekanntermaßen darunter sind aber
es gibt auch in der AFD Menschen die
sich untereinander politisch überhaupt
nicht grün sind und deren
Weltanschauungen weit auseinander gehen
genau und wenn wir einen Zettel drauf
kleben und ein Etikett da drauf machen
als Nazis und das hat man ist ja auch in
den Leitmedien oft genug passiert
dann gehen wir an dem was 10% der
Bevölkerung in diesem Land denken
komplett vorbei ja wir sagen Ihnen was
du denkst ist illegitim und das können
wir nicht machen wir können sehr gute
Gründe dafür aufführen warum Leute die
nicht auf dem Boden unserer Verfassung
stehen das sind Nazis dass wir die nicht
in Talkshows einladen oder ihnen keine
Stimme geben dass wir aber Menschen die
auf dem Boden unserer Verfassung stehen
und die rechts von der CDU stehen dass
die deswegen quasi als illegitime
Stimmen wahrgenommen werden ist ein
Problem das kann man nicht machen im
Sinne einer die liberativen und
integrativen Demokratie genau und ich
habe das nur als Beispiel dafür genannt
ich mich hat diese Reportage damals die
über ein sehr langen Zeitraum ging ja
die sehr lange begleitet wahnsinnig
beeindruckt weil ich dachte guck mal das
ist das was Journalismus leisten kann
ein differenziertes Bild zu zeichnen
Langzeitbeobachtung wirklich mal
erklären für und wieder verschiedene
Positionen zu sein damals einen Eindruck
davon zu geben wie dort eigentlich eine
Gemengelage ist und wie es passieren
kann dass man Teile der Bevölkerung
einfach wirklich verliert und dass uns
Dinge wirklich aus dem Ruder laufen und
dass wir gut beraten sind genau
zuzuhören genau hinzusehen und deswegen
auch mein meiner Pell immer wieder ich
rede darüber auch oft mit Freunden
liest die langen Stücke guckt euch die
langen Stücke an nehmt euch die Zeit und
wenn es eine Bleiwüste ist lest es
trotzdem durch und zwar von Anfang bis
Ende weil es gibt darin häufig in und da
haben wir großartige Beispiele in
deutschen Zeitungen aber auch in
Reportagen auch des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehens
großartige Beispiele dafür wie
differenziert man Dinge eben aufdröseln
kann
und ich ich habe manchmal das Gefühl wir
machen es uns zu einfach mit so einer
Pauschalkritik an den Medien weil die
Medien die habe ich nicht gemacht
ich habe nicht die Medien kritisiert und
das zweite ist ich habe nicht die Medien
diskreditiert und schon gar nicht die
Journalisten weil die Journalisten und
die Medien gibt es nicht sondern ich
kritisiere bestimmte Tendenzen aber ich
kann dir bei dem was du gesagt hast
völlig zustimmen was ihr brauchen ist
mehr Informationen mit der wir uns
wirklich beschäftigen
und weniger schnelle Moral mit der wir
die Dinge beurteilen dann werden wir
schon großen Schritt weiter Markus das
war ein gutes Gespräch sehr ich danke
dir dafür sehr gerne bis bald bis bald
Ciao
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]